[музика]
доброго Та мирного дня шановні колеги
раді вітати вас на локації дошкільна
освіта під крилами захисту в рамках
міжнародної серпневої педагогічної
науково-практичної конференції освіта
освітянин незламної війни
модераторами цієї зустрічі є я Світлана
нерянова начальник відділу дошкільної
освіти Міністерства освіти і науки
України та Ольга Косинчук кандидат
педагогічних наук доцент начальник
відділу дошкільної та початкової освіти
державної установи українські інститут
розвитку освіти
сьогодні несло корективи в освітянське
життя та незмінним лишилося ти що Усі ми
маємо працювати заради наших дітей
робота кожного наразі надзвичайно
важливо у стані війни діти дошкільного
віку належать до найвразливішої
категорії населення
перебуваючи в небезпеці тривалому
стресовому стані дитина позбавлена
нормальних умов для розвитку та освіти
через відчуття тривоги напруги страху
невизначеності ускладнюється процес
повноцінної соціалізації дитини діти які
вимушені були переміщеними бути із зони
активних бойових дій стикаються з
проблемою соціальної адаптації
перебуваючи в Нових соціальних умовах
відповідь на запитання щодо особливостей
організації освітнього процесу в
закладах дошкільної освіти під час
воєнного стану будуть сфокусовані у
виступах наших спікерів хоч нагадати що
захід проводиться в онлайн-форматі
тривалість якого буде з 14 до 16 години
Дорогі колеги трансляція секції
дошкільна освіта під крилами захисту
відбувається на youtube-каналах
Міністерства освіти і науки України а
також видавництва Ранок нагадую вам про
дотримання правил безпеки і в разі
сигналу повітряної тривоги
неодмінно прослідковуйте в укриття у
зручний для вас час ви зможете
переглянути запис сьогоднішньої зустрічі
на сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
України українського інституту розвитку
освіти а також видавництво Ранок
для вітального слова та відкриття заходу
нашого Запрошуємо голову під комітету з
питань раннього розвитку та дошкільної
освіти комітету Верховної Ради України з
питань освіти науки та інновацій
Володимира Воронова Володимира
Анатолійович пан слово будь ласка
Дуже дякую
Доброго дня
шановні освітяни радий що на незважаючи
на нові реалії сьогодення
ви всі змогли доєднатися до нашої
конференції наразі завдяки
вам ми маємо важливість зберегти
дошкілля та надати офлайн онлайн доступ
для тих хто цього потребує наразі
Україна з кожним днем та швидше
змінюється та трансформується
зароджуються нові технології оновлюються
програми підходи і
Ми дуже швидко навчилися працювати
онлайн і Ми наразі як ніколи маємо
підтримувати цей прогрес адже Україна
наразі на першому місці у світі серед
зацікавленості і підтримки наразі
найкращий час відкрити двері та
дозволити собі також кожному з нас
впустити прогрес та рухатись вперед
українське дошкілля освіта і піклування
Нова країна дошкільної освіти
Бажаю всім Гарного дня та гарно
попрацювати
Дякуємо Володимир Анатолійовичу за ваша
надихаючу
надихаючи вітальні слова і хочеться
сказати про те що освіта не існує без
науки і в рамках тісної співпраці
Міністерства освіти і науки України з
національною академії педагогічних наук
України вирішується актуальні питання чи
до розвитку дітей раннього та
дошкільного віку і зараз дорогі друзі
пропонуємо вашій увазі відеозвернення
Світлани сосоєвої дійсного члена
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України доктора педагогічних наук
професора Академіка секретаря-відділення
загальної педагогіки та філософії освіти
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України
Шановні колеги Шановні представники
наймолодшої ланки нашої освіти
наймолодшою але найбільш відповідальної
Бо саме в ці роки в дошкільному віці
закладаються основи розвитку особистості
людини у подальшому її життєвого успіху
сьогодні наше серпневі конференції
проходять в дуже важкий час для нашої
рідної України
в країні йде війна Ми кожен день
починаємо з новин ми читаємо Як
просунулися наше веселу за добу які
події відбуваються Ми чуємо тривоги в
країні ми вже до них десь звикли Але ми
не можемо ніколи звикнути до того що йде
війна ніколи до поки не буде Перемоги
України
професійна стане мир в нашій рідній
оселі Я хочу сказати що сьогодні ми всі
представники єдиного фронту якщо ми
працюємо на перемогу то ми намагаємося
кожен на своєму місці виконувати свої
посадові обов'язки і не просто їх
виконувати а робити все можливе щоб наша
професійна діяльність була спрямована на
наближення Перемоги України на
відновлення нашої країни на майбутнє
нашої країни а майбутнє нашої країни це
наші діти і те наскільки ми зможемо
сьогодні їх захистити
убезпечити
донести до батьків як потрібно діяти в
цих непростих умовах щоб дитина не
відчувала психологічного стресу щоб вона
найбільше могла користуватися до таких
умов життя в цьому сьогодні полягає наша
з вами дуже Велика місія
багато дітей виїхали сьогодні за межі
України багато дітей разом з їхніми
матусями блукають по світу і ми маємо
зробити все можливе щоб наші діточки
повернулися до України Бо їм треба далі
працювати щоб відновлювати Україну Я
хочу сказати що дуже позитивним є такий
от така подія сьогодні у дошкіллі це
створення такого
онлайн-ресурсу дуже потужного дошкілля
України освіта і піклування яке
безкоштовно
надає консультації батькам
вихователям як діяти в таких непростих
умовах сьогодні вже на цій
онлайн-платформі зареєстрована 21 тисяча
електронних кабінетів а кожним
електронним Кабінетом стоїть і матуся і
бабуся і група вихователів і тому можна
через таку платформу донести до кожного
з них як треба
сприяти розвитку дитини навіть в такий
важкий час я хочу вам побажати сьогодні
вам я неправильно сказала всім нам
побажати сьогодні Щоб наша робота була
плідне щоб наші виступи були не просто
теоретичними узагальненнями щоб наші
виступи не просто були спрямовані І
розказували про наші досягнення і
дослідження а перш за все вони були
через призму того часу в якому ми живемо
через
воєнний стан в країні І що ми маємо
зробити щоб своєї професійної працею
наблизити перемогу і відновлення нашої
країни Хай сьогодні наша робота буде
головний а й Сьогодні ми обміняємося
досвідами візьмемо щось найкраще для
себе щось зрозуміємо в цій ситуації
важкій для нас слава Україні тебе щось
зрозуміємо в цій ситуації важкій для нас
слава Україні
Героям слава і життя ставить перед нами
нові закладів дошкільної освіти усіх
типів і форм власності до початку нового
2022-2023 року
створення безпечних умов перебування у
них всіх учасників освітнього процесу з
урахуванням збройної агресії Російської
Федерації Це одні із ключових питань які
перебувають на особливому контролі уряду
і про особливості організації
освітньо-виховного процесу в закладах
дошкільної освіти та рекомендації
почергових кроків із підготовки до нього
У своєму виступі розкриє начальник
відділу дошкільної освіти Міністерства
освіти і науки України Світлана мірянова
Світлана Іванівна вам Слово Життя
ставить перед нами нові виклики і
потребує нових рішень у досягненні
головної мети зберегти життя і здоров'я
дітей забезпечити їх психологічну
підтримку та сприяти всебічному розвитку
дітей будь ласка наступний слайд
яка ж дошкільна освіта Була довільно
функціонувало майже 15 тисяч закладів
дошкільної освіти в яких виховувались
більше 1 млн 111 000 дітей відповідного
Віку І що ми маємо на сьогодні А на
сьогодні лише чуть більше двох тисяч
закладів приймають дітей у двох з
половиною тисячах організовано різні
форми дистанційної роботи з батьками та
дітьми і 190 закладів використовують
змішану форму надання освітніх послуг
Але разом з тим більше 8 тисяч дітей із
числа внутрішньо переміщених вже
зараховані до дошкільних закладів і
прийняли на роботу вже 85 педагогічних
працівників будь ласка наступний слайд
на превеликий жаль стану на 11 серпня
747 закладів дошкільної освіти вже
пошкоджено
74 зруйновано і на превеликий жаль ця
цифра постійно зростає
1400 перебувають на непідконтрольній
Україні території тому їх доля повністю
нам невідома будь ласка наступний слайд
такі на превеликий жаль в нашій реалії
роботи закладів дошкільної освіти під
час воєнного стану організовується
звичайно залежно від конкретної ситуації
в даному населеному пункті та з
урахуванням заходів і завдань визначених
військово-цивільною адміністрацією та
засновником закладів
Сьогодні лише 605 захисних споруд
цивільного захисту знаходяться на
балансі закладів дошкільної освіти і дві
з половиною тисячі мають укриття разом з
найпростішими укриттями інших суб'єктів
господарювання але хочу відмітити і
позитивний
найбільше забезпечено укриттям закладів
дошкільної освіти у місті Києві 60%
Львівській області 60 Закарпатський 37
Тернопільський 34
івано-франківський 33 Черкаський 33
Одеський 31 та Кіровоградський 30% від
закладів дошкільної освіти будь ласка
наступний слайд
на цих фотографіях ви бачите які захисні
споруди у нас були на початок війни
Це ті захисні споруди і які ще не
облаштовані але в яких вже перебували
діти під час повітряних тривів тому наше
завдання зробити цій укриття більш
комфортними для наших дітей будь ласка
наступний слайд
дошкільна освіта України з 1 вересня що
ж ми плануємо а заплановано відновити
роботу в
10-1689 закладах дошкільної освіти
і заплановано що послуги будуть
отримувати більше 700 тисяч дітей
відповідного віку зокрема планують у
звичному режимі А це значить приймати
дітей 4 тисячі вісімсот закладів
дистанційно працювати
4750 із змішану форму заплановану
організувати в 1150 закладах дошкільної
освіти Ось такі наші перспективи і плани
будь ласка наступний слайд
Міністерство освіти звичайно не
лишається без
уваги і
заклади дошкільної освіти і надає
рекомендації які допоможуть на сьогодні
в роботі саме військових умовах закладах
дошкільної освіти Хочу звернути вашу
увагу на листи Міністерство освіти і
науки щодо окремих питань діяльності
закладів дошкільної у
2022-23 навчальному році
не лишаємо без уваги дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами тому
підготовлено лист щодо забезпечення
освіти осіб з особливими освітніми
потребами і в умовах війни
важливою складовою освітнього процесу є
просвітницька робота з усіма учасниками
освітнього процесу щодо питань уникнення
враження мінами вибухонебезпечними
предметами та ознайомлення з правилами
поводження в надзвичайних ситуаціях
не менш важливе є збереження мережі
закладів дошкільної освіти і захисту
прав їх працівників
також в допомогу
підготовлено лист щодо зарахування до
закладів дошкільної освіти дітей із
числа внутрішньо переміщених осіб всі ці
листи ви можете знайти на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки України її
не в розділі дошкільна освіта будь ласка
наступний слайд
на сьогодні
є проблема з
наданням освітніх послуг дітям
дошкільного віку
міністерстві розроблено такі моделі
освітнього процесу перше це дитина яка
знаходиться в Україні на безпечній
території а її місце проживання не
змінилось або Вона повернулась на
постійне місце проживання може бути
застосована очна форма освіти
дистанційна або змішана здо в закладі
дошкільної освіти де раніше перебували
діти або також може використовуватись і
сімейна форма освіти друга модель дитина
є внутрішньо переміщеною особою Звичайно
це може бути очна за новим місцем
проживання
дистанційна в закладі які відвідувала
дитина раніше або за місцем теперішнього
проживання
вирішена або сімейна третя форма модель
дитина знаходиться на тимчасово
окупованій території звичайно тут ми
можна запропонувати дистанційну форму
здобуття дошкільної освіти на
підконтрольній території або сімейну з
використанням доступних онлайн ресурсів
які розміщено на сайті міністерства в
рубриці дошкільна освіта
четверта модель дитина знаходиться за
кордоном
учня дитина може здобувати дошкільну
освіту в закладі дошкільної освіти
країни перебування або дистанційно в
закладі дошкільної освіти на безпечній
території а також сімейною формою де
батьки можуть використовувати всі
доступні онлайн-ресурси далі будь ласка
на сьогодні у нас найголовніше завдання
- це зберегти життя і здоров'я наших
дітей та створити безпечні умови в
закладах дошкільної освіти
Яву впевнена що ми прикладемо для цього
всі наші старання будь ласка наступні
слайд
я щиро вдячна всім за увагу і хочу
запропонувати переглянути відеоролик про
облаштування укриттів в закладі
дошкільної освіти міста Рівного
Спасибі за увагу буде мир в Україні
Слава Україні у Рівному є дитячий
садочок У якому укриття облаштоване
згідно всіх правил та вимог мова про
приватних дошкільний навчальний заклад
бейбіленд так звичайно я був в цьому
укриті Ну що я можу сказати це є для нас
орієнтир до чого потрібно прагнути Які
садочки мають бути і комунальні і
державні і будь-які інші і які в них
мають бути укриття і не тільки садочки А
взагалі всі об'єкти бебіленти - це ж
найновіший заклад Фактично це заклад
приватний і в них укриттям їхнє сховище
зроблено вже відповідно до всіх вимог і
стандартів Такий вигляд має сховище
приватного садочку babyland раніше на
цокольному рівні знаходився центр
розвитку дитини Baby Club Саме тут діти
мали змогу ви чоловік англійську мову
малювати у творчій кімнаті займатись
танцями та багато іншого Нині ж це
приміщення використовується не лише за
призначенням але й у якості укриття
Фактично це вже було пристосоване
приміщення підвальне щоб зробити більш
комфортне перебування діток в нашому
закладі особливо під час денного сну не
дай боже що якщо виникне якась тривога
чи небезпека ми прийняли рішення
класти діток на денний сон чи ні щоб
дітки перебували під час денного сну в
безпеці для цього ми перенесли ліжечка і
обладнали спальні в нашому сховищі
садочок розрахований на 120 дітей а
загальна площа укриття становить понад
1000 квадратних метрів що дає змогу
розмістити усіх дошкільнят в разі
повітряної тривоги тут є все необхідне
два санвузли три виходи з укриття запас
їжі та води 6 кімнат на цокольному рівні
було облаштовано як спальні для малюків
та ще 6 слугують ігровими кімнатами
окрім того сховище у садочку має свою
систему опа та навіть оснащене екстреним
освітленням у вигляді світлодіодних
аварійних джерел світла що зможуть
працювати протягом кількох годин після
відключення електроенергії під час
повітряної тривоги кожен вихователь
дитсадку має чіткий план організації
дітей для проведення їх в укриття для
цього в нас є чітко розроблений план дій
вихователі і весь персонал чітко знають
що які дії приймаємо що робимо коли
вчить сигнал повітряної тривоги ми
шикуємося
вихователь спереді стає і взаді
помічники йдем подвал і чим ми
займаєтесь
або займаємося з цифрами або буквами ми
малюємо розфарбовуємо подивимось
мультики Не страшно зовсім
окрім чітких вказівок дій вихователя під
час повітряної тривоги на кожну групу
передбачено тривожна валізка в нас на
кожній групі є такий маленька така
тривожна валізка і це з є взаємодія
вихователь сюди входить
Ось така торбинка в якій є бейджиків вся
інформація про дітей і у нас є на кожну
дитинку на кожну грубку розпіратори на
випадок якоїсь небезпеки і папка і папка
з інформацією з планом дій з алгоритмом
дій вихователя на час
повітряної тривоги
і дуже сподіваюся що не тільки в Рівному
а по всій Україні у нас будуть такі
захисні споруди зручні і комфортабельні
для наших дітей маленьких
в 2021 році затверджено стандарт
дошкільної освіти який сприяє підвищенню
якості дошкільної освіти в Україні
відповідає міжнародним критеріям та
стандартам
оновлений стандарт відповідно до вимог
сьогодення який наразі активно
імплементується в закладах дошкільної
освіти тож які шляхи подальшої
реалізації державного стандарту
дошкільної освіти в сучасних умовах Ми
маємо можливість обговорити це питання з
керівником робочої групи з розробки
стандарту доктору психологічних наук
професором завідувачкою лабораторії
психології дошкільника інституту
психології імені Костюка Національної
академії педагогічних наук України члени
кореспондента Національної академії
педагогічних наук України Тамарою
піроженко Тамара Олександрівна вам слово
Добрий день шановні Добрий день шановні
дошкільники Вітаю вас у просторі
Міжнародної конференції яка присвячена
проблемам розвитку дошкільної освіти в
сучасних умовах теми виступу пов'язана з
головним документом який
визначає розвиток дошкільної галузі
стандартом дошкільної освіти ми
поговоримо про цей стандарт які
визначають
очікуваний результат дошкільної освіти а
також ті вимоги які забезпечують
результат і я хочу сказати що зараз ми
зовсім в іншу умовах чим в тих часи коли
писалося цей документ він був написаний
в мирний часи і для мирного життя і
постає питання чи можливо зараз
впровадити всі ці настанови положення
вимоги стандарту дошкільної освіти Чи не
є це питання не актуальним зай для
сьогодення оскільки потрібно
впроваджувати стандарт дошкільної освіти
це питання дійсно актуальне вони
своєчасно Але ж я хочу підтримати всіх
цих фахівців дошкільних галузі які
вважають що дошкільної освіти України
потребує подальшої уваги розвитку
збереження всіх цих надбань які ми маємо
і про це так само підтверджує
аналітичний звіт який був представлений
на матеріалі міжнародно визнано
інструментарію дошкільної освіти
інструментарію ekerstream які вказує на
те що дошкільну галузь України Вона має
своє здобутки своє напрацювання
нормативно-правову базу і багато-багато
досягнень які потребують подальшої уваги
і подальшого розвитку тому І до того ж я
хочу сказати що Україна є учасником
програми дії Юнеско програми освіта 2030
яка визначає вимоги до того тому що
держава бере на себе
зобов'язання щодо
можливості отримати освіту якісну
доступну освіту для всіх громадян
України тому повернемось до нашого
стандарту як відомо з 21-го року як коли
вибух прийнятий стандарт Він багато був
обговорений на сторінках газети журналів
наших видань багато проведено вебінара в
семінарах і тому зараз не її метою
пояснення специфіки самого документу Але
ж я прошу звернути далі вже на сторінку
там
3-4 нашого слайду але я хочу звернути
увагу на те що дійсно специфікою
дошкільної освіти є те що результатом
цієї ланки є сформована компетентність
прошу четвертий слайд
сформована компетентність і це
це очікувано це очікуваний результат дає
нам можливість дійсно звернути
наше розуміння на те звернути увагу до
того що
компетентність є не просто феноліном
який нутеріотично обґрунтований Чому
вони змінює взагалі
знання радіємо на компетентнісно і це
світова практика світовий тренд в освіті
які характеризують не тільки дошкільну і
загальну середню освіту і вищу школу і
так далі компетентність - це феномен
який показує що завданням і результатом
дошкільної галузі є сформованість в
якому збережена цілісність розвитку
дитини прошу четвертий кадр слайд
на цьому слайді ми бачимо що дошкільна
галузь має різне освітні напрямки і
дитину в соці встановлені і дитина в
природному довкіллі гра і дитина в світі
мистецтва всю сторону пізнавальному
просторі і так далі внутрішнє коло це
діаграми вказує на те що відповідно до
кожного освітнього напряму є відповідний
компетентності і так само Ми давно вже
зробили висновок і практики Це
підтверджує що всі ці компетентності
залежить від збагачення досвіду
діяльності дитини інакше кажучи з чим
більше чим більше років кола діяльності
як я опановує дитина втім більше і
якісніше представляє дитину сформований
компетентності але ж які види діяльності
Я хочу звернути увагу на те що цю
діяльність суто специфічних для
дошкільних галузі специфічними для
дошкільної дідактики це діяльності
ігрова комунікативне спілкування рухова
мистецтво пізнавальна і господарча
побутова це теж для нас не нове але
Звертаю увагу на те що учбо
спеціальності і навчальної діяльності в
переліку специфічних діяльності
дошкільної галузі немає учбова
діяльність і навчальна діяльність це
діяльність для шкільного етапу життя і
наступному слайді Я хочу звернути нашу
увагу на те що весь освітній потенціал
сформованих очікуваних компетентностей
дійсно залежить від широти сформованих
дітей діяльності але змінився умови і
дійсно не кожний садочок має умови для
організації та мистецької діяльності
рухової навіть в пізнавальне
дослідницький і тут я хочу поділитися з
вами
декілька незвичним положеннями
зустрічної опозицією яка дивно виглядає
з уст психолога Тим паче психолога які є
денним керівником стандарту про що я
хочу сказати про що потрібно подумати
разом специфіка полягає в тому що різні
види компе дійсності можна сформувати на
одному виді діяльності
будь-якому мистецькій діяльності
комунікативна ігрової побутовий це не
залежить від широти від діяльності це
ідеал дійсно ми будемо намагатися
створювати розширювати ці умови для
різних видів діяльності але головне в
компетентності щоб дитина об'єднала
емоції
захват бажання інтереси прагнення
якогось відео діяльності з потрібними
знаннями і далі і це головне ці знання і
емоції могла впроваджувати в реальні дії
в реальних задумах в реальній практиці в
реальні проекти в реальні плани в
реальні мрії і от цей зв'язок між
емоціями знаннями інтелектом і вольовою
регуляції Це її феномен компетентності
Тому це не є теоретичний конструкт це є
то досягнення психологічно яке є
результатом нашого захоплюючого
спільного такого
спільної взаємодії з дитиною і це
вимагає від педагогів проаналізувати
свої сильні сторони тобто які умови У
вас є в садочку які сильні сторони
демонструє педагог і Можливо якщо
мистецька діяльність є пріоритетом і він
є найвищим майстром в організації
мистецької діяльності він на фоні
мистецької діяльності своїм захватам
своїм інтересам своїм натхненням на цю
діяльність так само захоплює активну
позицію дитини і активна розширює досвід
пошуку потрібної інформації і можливості
використовувати цю інформацію в
реальному житті тому я б хотіла
звернути нашу увагу на те що цей
унікальний феномен компетентність він
дійсно потребує
від нас дорослих відмовитись від
формального підходу до реалізації
стандарту відмовитися від профанації не
потрібно будь-якою ціною розширювати всі
види діяльності якщо немає відповідних
умов але потрібно дійсно організувати
діяльність такий спосіб відповідно до
специфіки сприйняття оточуючи освіту
дитини в такий спосіб щоб емоції
інтелекту Воля були об'єднані і тоді на
фоні цієї компетентності яку ви
сформували наприклад будь-якого виду
діяльності ви можете помножувати
збагачувати масштабувати знання із
дослідницької практики і знання з
математики і знання з природи
художній творчості Ну і так далі І так
далі і в наступному слайді Я хочу
звернути нашу увагу те що дійсно ця це
очікуваний результат компетентність це
єдність між емоціями інтелектом і волі і
вони формують От ця єдність цей феномен
психологічний формують дійсно ці
наскрізні вміння який виступають
маркером сформоване компетентності які є
обов'язковими І
вказником що дитина Готова до школи до
систематичного навчання школа ці мішки
навички ці наскрізні навички це вміння
керувати емоціями висловлювати свою
думку або ґрунтовувати приймати рішення
проявляти ініціативність І взагалі
співпрацювати з іншими людьми і от ці
навички і ще раз повторюю вони дійсно є
м'якими вони відносяться до будь-якої
діяльності і вони є способом формування
наступного кроку
які потребує від дитини вмінь в
подальшому систематичному шкільному
навчанні і наступний кадр він звертає
нашу увагу на те слайд прошу що є і інше
друга специфічна характеристика сучасних
сучасної ситуації впровадження стандарту
це характеристика зв'язана з тим що
вперше стандарт дошкільної освіти
конкретизує всі вимоги до батьків як
реальний учасників освітнього процесу
тобто батьки виступають суб'єктами
сучасної освіти і конкретизація вимог і
конкретних дій батьків вихованців вона
спрямовує нашу увагу на те щоб педагоги
на сьогодні повинно якось розширювати
практику спільний взаємодії з батьками і
вихованцем розширюйте практику
партнерської взаємодії шукати новий
способи
цих контактів сучасних способи
дискусійний і платформи і спільні ідеї
спільної практики і консультування Тобто
Це дійсно сучасна задача для педагогів і
для всіх колективів дошкільних закладів
освіти чим більше партнер взаємодії буде
розвинена тим більше ми отримуємо вищий
рівень сформованих результатів
компетентності тому що для дитини
дошкільного віку батьки залишаються
головним фактором розвитку І до того ж
батьки супроводжує розвиток дитини і в
подальшому шкільного освіти там і навіть
у вишитій школі і от та довіра між
батьками і педагогами соціальними
працівниками психологами це є то таким
фондом які дуже-дуже є корисним фактором
підтримки розвитку дітей тобто других
аспект характеризують
які важливе врахувати
впровадженні стандарту це співпраця з
батьками і наступний третій момент який
є характерними про що наступний слайд їх
характерним для сьогодення
в стандарті дошкільної освіти
прописана одна із цілей цього стандарту
як документу це
забезпечення наступності між дошкільної
та початковою школою і це наступне між
дошкільної та початкової освіти вона
реалізується
різними способами про це теж Ми багато
говорили але що означає
сьогодення Що означає сучасна ситуація
сучасна ситуація розвитку дитини показує
що В умовах воєнного стану і воєнних дій
військових дій дитина
пропустила
цілий рік соціалізації тобто багато
дітей як ми бачимо і статистики
взагалі не відвідували дитячий садок і
рік соціалізації є пропущеним і що ж
робити думаю що конкретно моментом які
показує нашу психологічну грамотність
нашу позицію стосовно дитини це є
рішення
стосовно вступу дитину в перший клас
школи і Оскільки ми не порушуємо закон
про освіту закон про дошкільну освіту в
яких сказано що дошкільний період - це
період до 6-7 років життя І от це
інформація сьомий рік життя є дуже є
важливим для того щоб
приділити увагу дитині яка завтра іде до
школи починає систематичне навчання в
школі ми враховуємо що в умовах
отруйнуванні системи дошкільного
виховання діти які не отримують цей
досвід соціалізації вони потребують
додаткової підтримки до того ж дитина у
нас багато дітей які разом з сім'ями
перебувають за кордоном За кордоном вони
йдуть до школи в перший клас 7 років так
наприклад в прибалті це в Польщі і це
означає що в другому третьому класі Ці
діти зустрінуться в одному класі вони як
рогове скільки будуть в третьому там в
другому класі і це нормальна ситуація
але ж це формальна ситуація головне
приділити уваги саме ваших дітей
дитині і Інститут психології наша
лабораторії лабораторія психології
дошкільника розробили
експрес-діагностику щодо готовності
дитини досить тематичного навчання в
школі і ця
діагностика експрес-діагностика вона
побудована саме на маркерах
компетентнісного підходу тобто що
очікується від дитини в умовах школи які
опанування які досягнення має дитина щоб
дійсно спокійно і ефективно провести
свою перехід Я хочу сказати що якщо ця
діагностика вказує на те що всі
досягнення там дошкільної зрілості
дійсно реалізоване і дитина смілива
спокійна і
гарно може зробити цей крок то дійсно
Нехай вона йде в 6 років але ж багато
дітей потребують додаткової уваги в
зв'язку з відсутністю цього року
дошкільного життя в умовах освітнього
закладу і тому так само спокійно нам
потрібно надати дитині цей рік для
соціалізації Я думаю що це було
правильно рішення воно свідоме рішення
воно на користь дитині І до того ж всі
освітні програми в школі вони
вираховувати вікові закономірності
розвитку шостий чи сьомий рік життя і
тому так змінено у нас
формат життєдіяльності в першому класі
за реформою української нової школи тому
я хочу сказати що ми закономірності віку
збережені індивідуальності дитини
повинна ставити і на цьому наша
специфічна грамотна позиція з погляду
впровадження стандартів дошкільної
освіти Я думаю що це потрібно так само
обговорювати і надавати батькам підстави
для таких свідомих правильних грамотних
рішень от ці три особливості Я думаю що
вона потрібна звернути увагу
коли ми розуміємо що дошкільної освіти
призначена для дитини і ми все робимо
для того щоб її всебічний розвиток
гармонійний розвиток в умовах таких
страшних випробувань наша державах були
підтриманий дорослими грамотними діями
дорослих і на останнє в нашій бесіді Я б
хотіла сказати слова які я випадково
почула А можу можливо і не випадково
вони звучать так ми всі чекаємо на краще
а воно
це воно чекає на нас на нашу активність
на нашу відповідальність на нашу
грамотність Я думаю що ми це всі
розуміємо як фахівці дошкільних галузі і
тримаємо стрій єднаємось в наших
спільних зусиллях Дякую вам за спільну
роботу
України спільно з українським інститутом
розвитку освіти в партнерстві з
видавництвом ранок в рамках
всеукраїнського онлайн-марафону
реалізація змісту державного стандарту
дошкільної освіти в комплексних та
парціальних освітніх програмах
проводяться щотижневі зустрічі з
освітянською спільнотою на сьогодні до
марафону долучилися авторські колективи
розробників програм що дає можливість
детально ознайомитися з програмами
педагогам батькам А також обрати для
роботи закладу чинні програми та
обговорити особливості їх впровадження у
воєнний час запрошую до слова доктора
педагогічних наук професора Наталію
Гавриш та кандидата педагогічних наук
доцента начальника відділу дошкільної та
початкової освіти українського інституту
розвитку освіти Ольгу косенчук шановні
колеги вам слово
Доброго Доброго дня шановні колеги ми з
України і готуючись розпочати новий
Навчальний рік у таких складних умовах
сьогодення щоб не втратити підростаюче
покоління ми маємо навчитися діяти В
умовах воєнного освітнього процесу
одним із досягнень довоєнної дошкільної
освіти в Україні є
активний процес програмотворення який
цілком виправдано для держави яка є
демократичною народження не єдиною
уніфікованою типовою програми а саме
низки різноманітних програм надав
можливість педагогічним колективам та
окремим педагогам обирати одну з чинних
освітніх програм за власними
вподобаннями враховуючи регіональний
компонент і специфіку самого закладу
дошкільної освіти
враховуючи націленість та інтереси
педагогічних колективів У своєму виступі
Ми дамо короткі огляд чинних програм і
розкриємо особливості їх впровадження у
воєнний час
наступний слайд будь ласка
затверджений на початку 2021 року
державний стандарт дошкільної освіти
спричинив потребу у оновленні перегляді
всіх чинних програм саме задля
забезпечення їх відповідності нові
редакції базового компоненту дошкільної
освіти
процес стандартизації змісту дошкільної
освіти торкнувся також і термінології і
визначення сутності програмових
документів які мали до того ж зберігаючи
специфіку дошкільної освіти
узгоджувалися з іншими освітніми
стандартами в Україні виокремлено два
види програм це комплексна програма і
парціальна програма на наступному слайді
ви можете побачити визначення що означає
комплексна і порціальна програма Я б
хотіла прокоментувати що комплексна
освітня програма - це нормативний
документ який має комплекс освітніх
компонентів вони орієнтовані на
досягнення дітьми дошкільного віку всіх
стандартів всіх результатів дошкільної
освіти і що найважливіше що комплексна
освітня Програма вона відповідає
державному стандарту
на сьогоднішній день парціальна програма
за документ який містить перелік
освітніх компонентів в яких зазначені
завдання показники досягнення способи
реалізації змісту в межах одного або
кількох освітніх напрямів відповідно до
державного стандарту дошкільної освіти і
комплексні парціальні програми мають
бути затверджені
міністерством освіти і науки України
тобто
рекомендовані для впровадження в
закладах шкільної освіти на наступному
слайді ви можете побачити перелік
комплексних програм наголошую що в
дошкільних навчальних закладів це не
одна не дві програми Наразі у нас
чинними є 7 освітніх програм всім
комплексних програм які впроваджуються
в Україні це і програма впевнений старт
це комплект освітніх програм для дітей
дошкільного молодшого середнього і
старшого дошкільного віку стежинки
Всесвіт комплексна програма програма
дитина українська дошкілля я у світі
освіта і піклування Стежина це
комплексна альтернативна програма для
дошкільних навчальних закладів що
працюють за вальдорфською педагогікою
тобто специфіка кожної програми різна
але всі вони відповідають базовому
компоненту тобто державному стандарту
дошкільної освіти і рекомендовані для
впровадження в закладах дошкільної
освіти на наступному слайді ви можете
побачити
покликання на сайт інституту
модернізації змісту освіти де зазначено
перелік чинних програм як комплексних
так і парціальних вони постійно
оновлюються вони постійно
вдосконалюються збільшується тому всіх
сьогоднішніх глядачів Запрошуємо
переглянути перелік чинних програм на
сьогоднішній день це всім комплексних
програм і 23 парціальні програми які
орієнтовані на різні напрями освітньої
діяльності має сказати одне що
[музика]
всі програми вони відповідають стандарту
і вони достойні для того щоб бути
впроваджені ваших закладах українське
дошкілля найкраще тому і програми вони
зможуть доповнити якісно ваше освітній
процес і для того
щоб більш детальніше ознайомитися з
програмами на наступний слайд будь
ласочка що більш детальніше ознайомитися
з програмами Ми запрошуємо вас
долучитися до всеукраїнського
онлайн-марафону реалізація змісту
державного стандарту дошкільної освіти в
комплексних та парціальних програмах
який організований міністерством освіти
і науки України спільно з українським
інститутом розвитку освіти у партнерстві
з видавництвом ранок наразі на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки є окрема
рубрика де ви можете ознайомитися
з кожної парціальної програми з кожним
комплексною програмою до речі за участі
авторських колективів які їх презентують
безумовно
зараз всі колективи готуються до початку
нового навчального року
і я хочу зазначити що кожен навчальний
заклад має змогу обирати програму на
свій смак Тим більше що нема такої яка б
не декларувала в якості ціннісних
орієнтирів створення умов для
саморозвитку особистості
позитивного цінність того ставлення до
себе та навколишнього світу і
необхідно зазначити що
педагогічний колектив має бути
ознайомлений з усіма програмами а заклад
має право на автономність вибору даних
програм проте яким чином реалізувати
програму на практиці в такий складний
воєнний час ми з вами зараз поговоримо
Наталя Василівна запрошуємо вас до слова
будь ласка
і Доброго дня дорога дошкільна
українська родина ми дійсно
продовжуючи вашу думку дійсно говоримо
зараз про таку прогресивну орієнтацію
чинних програм на особистісний розвиток
на ціннісні пріоритети визначення
державним стандартом дошкільної освіти
але сама по собі програма на жаль не
гарантує реалізацію завдань
особистісного розвитку дошкільнят в
освітньому процесі закладу дошкільної
освіти
А що ж власне
викликом для педагогічних колективів в
новому навчальному році стає не сам
вибір комплексної чи парціальної
програми адже обирати як бачимо є з чого
йдеться про умови реалізації програми
державного стандарту в ситуації вільні
всі нам відомо що ситуації війни робить
небезпечно будь-який регіон нашої країни
і сигнал тривоги може пролунати в
будь-якій її частині А у прифронтовій
зоні реальної освітній процес часто
взагалі я неможливим і може відбуватися
лише в онлайн форматі Отже орієнтуючись
на якусь обраних програм маємо
враховувати реальні умови роботи
дошкільного закладу
задекларований раніше образ освітнього
процесу в якому жорсткий конструкт
планування і організація має змінитися
на реагування на живу ситуацію з
урахуванням реальних потреб інтересів
дітей можливостей педагога і самого
середовища дошкільного закладу тепер
стає необхідністю тож педагогічні
колективи мають діяти більш самостійно
відповідально усвідомлюючи всі ризики в
конкретних умовах у яких приходиться
працювати осмислено оцінювати свій
потенціал ресурси щоб зберегти себе і
дітей і реалізувати державний стандарт
адже можливості для повторення це більш
кращих умовах на жаль не буде і
по обставини різні загальні каркас
організації життєдіяльності дітей в
закладах дошкільної освітинь які живуть
в ситуації постійно готовності миттєво
зреагувати на сигнал тривоги саме от про
такі заклади ми будемо зараз говорити і
такі заклади інформація яка міститься на
слайді що ми зараз з вами бачимо
попри всі обставини
загальний каркас організації
життєдіяльності має зберігати свою
стабільність це дуже важливо для дітей
батьків самих педагогів але щоб
планування освітньої роботи було
реальним бажаємо доцільним примінити
спосіб потижневого планування коли
вихователі за неміченою темою визначають
освітні завдання і способи їх реалізації
готуйте тактичні засоби дидактичного
матеріалу на тиждень щоб потім
самостійно визначати найбільш
оптимальний час і спосіб ефективного
здійснювати запланований Отже планування
обов'язково має бути це такий
Якір які тримає
нас всіх у розумінні того що життя
продовжується воно має бути але ми
Радимо
обрати форму потижневого планування але
знову-таки кожен з вами з вас
думає і приймає рішення самостійно
вихователі мають орієнтуватися на
короткі за часом форми навчальних
взаємодії не більше 10-15 хвилин тобто
заняття як основну форму
навчально-пізнавальної діяльності а вона
не лише ця діяльність
притаманна дітям дошкільного віку краще
її умовно розділити на 2-4 частини чітко
визначивши їх методичний статус
наприклад розповідь там про щось читання
такого-то тексту спільну діяльність
дітей власне ці структурні елементи
завжди присутні в наших
конспектах робочих планах конспектах але
зараз їх треба бути готовими відокремити
один від одного і реалізувати не цілісну
в межах заняття а послідовно
відокремлена в часі вихователь І лише
вихователь Відчуваючи усвідомлюючи
реальний Стан свій і дітей має обирати
Як сам буде організовано навчальна
взаємодія саме тому і треба відмовитися
від традиційного описового формального
планування реалізації якого у значній
мірі залежить вже на жаль не від нас
прошу наступний слайд
але крім закладів які можуть працювати
наживо
дуже багато у нас
Майже понад третинний дошкільних
закладів заради безпеки дітей педагогів
були змушені перервати реальний робочі
процеси привести його в дистанційну
форму власне ось про Ці дві форми більш
детальніше ми розглядаємо дистанційну
форму освіти коли педагоги готують для
дітей батьків дидактичні матеріали А ті
надсилають їх А ті можуть
використовувати їх у зручний для себе
час вихователь може записати записати
фрагменти занять фрагменти інших видів
діяльності якісь
форми такі коротких спілкування з дітьми
і також надсилати в якості
необхідного дидактичного матеріалу для
дітей
але крім дистанційної форми є ще онлайн
формат освітнього процесу для педагогів
у кого і батьків у кого є можливість
проводити заняття синхронна з усіма
дітьми зрозуміло що не всі
форми роботи передбачені
нашої в нашому звичайному освітнім
процесом
можуть реалізуватися Через такі формат
Чому Тому що
ми не можемо тримати дітей педагогів
весь час навколо себе Отже залежно від
наявних можливостей ми можемо
використовувати тут форму чи ту форму а
можливо якось комбінувати їх і в першому
і в другому випадку
надзвичайно зростає роль батьків їх
участь в освітньому процесі їх суфікс
відповідальність за якість освіти своїх
дітей і
дійсно
надзвичайно важлива
вихователю в цьому його майстерність
полягає в тому щоб
запрошувати
мотивувати батьків працювати з дітьми
активніше для закладів дошкільної освіти
які проводять освітній процес онлайн
форматі найбільшого оптимальна форма
проведення занять з дітьми це
онлайн-зустрічі у формі ігрової
взаємодії тривалістю 10-15 хвилин за
таким алгоритмом Починаємо грати або
займатися мотивуємо дітей до спільної
діяльності Сьогодні
пізнавальну ситуацію продовжуємо гру або
продовжуємо навчальну ситуацію через
сукупність навчальної ігрових завдань і
граємо або діємо самостійно
разом з батьками і вихователі мають
запропонувати для самостійної е-е роботи
кілька можливих людей або такі ідеї
народжуються уже власне в родині Отже
новий навчальний рік потребуватиме від
кожного із нас особливої гнучкості у
підходах самостійності та
відповідальності переконані що в
методичній роботі на перший план має
вийти формування рефлексивних умінь у
вихователів підготовка педагога
фасилітатора людини здатної чути
аналізувати і реагувати миттєво діяти
успішну в живій ситуації взаємодії з
дітьми це один із основних викликів
воєнного освітнього процесу для більш
детального ознайомлення з програмою
радомимо переглядати наші вебінари про
чинні комплексні та парціальні програми
долучитися до участі у українському
онлайн Марафоні про який говорила Ольга
Геннадіївна Отже всім успіху в роботі
Дякую Шановні колеги І запрошую до слова
доктора філософії у сфері спеціальної
освіти старшого наукових співробітника
інституту раннього розвитку та
дошкільної освіти Національної академії
педагогічних наук України директора
компанії Містер лідел Глоба Наталію
піканова будь ласка пані Наталії
Дякую Шановні колеги дякую за запрошення
для Дякую що надали слово я рада всіх
вітати рада всіх вітати хто доєднався до
цієї чудової конференції і на честь того
що ви доєдналися невеличкий проміжок
часу звісно тому що дуже багато
виступаючих але
наша команда на честь цієї чудової
конференції та вирішила надати усім
абсолютно безкоштовний доступ до системи
повної системи освіти і піклування за
дітьми раннього та дошкільного віку
наразі ви можете побачити робити за мною
І на сайті Міністерства ви зможете
кожного дня бачити сайт Якщо ви
перейдете за посиланням тут буде у вас
telegram-канал Якщо ви підключитесь
додатково вище отримаєте обов'язково
календарно-тематичне планування на цілий
рік також абсолютно
без безкоштовно у подарунок і ви зможете
вже спланувати свою діяльність далі якщо
ми переглянемо з у системі ви можете
зареєструватися Так ось тут ви можете
побачити як виглядає да посилання воно
доступне абсолютно для всіх і
направлення для того щоб працювати як
батькам вдома так і виховательлю в
дошкільному закладі вона повністю готове
до використання і повністю прописані да
всі дидактичні матеріали також додатково
у вас буде У нас є комплексна програма
так у Також ви Абсолютно безкоштовно
можете використовувати на сайті І ви
знайдете її за посиланням наразі да
головне завдання - це зберегти дошкілля
України незалежно від того Де Ви
знаходитесь Можливо ви з дитиною за
кордоном а можливо ви вдома тут в
Україні і відповідно звісно вам потрібно
знати що робити на протязі дня дати тому
що можливо ви не маєте доступу до
дошкільних закладів і тому наша система
дозволяє вам незалежно від того у вас
комп'ютер у вас смартфон чи що Ви маєте
ви можете в будь-який момент
під'єднатися І у вас все готово до того
щоб на протязі дня провести якісно час з
дитиною да розписані всі заняття та всі
діяльності і відповідно ви можете цим
вже користуватися тому обов'язково Да я
ще раз дякую що Міністерство освіти що
академія наук підтриму інноваційні
технології підтримує інноваційні
програми тому дякую ще раз за запрошення
я Бажаю всім мирного неба да Бережіть
себе і
незалежно від того дерева знаходитесь
будь ласка користуйтеся усім у вас все в
доступному да комплексно все в доступі і
ви маєте можливість це робити я дуже
дякую всім гарного настрою пані Наталя
Дуже дякуємо вам дуже дякую вам що
створюєте якісні продукти і
популяризуєте їх і Шановні колеги щойно
була коротка презентація унікальної
програми догляд та піклування і Пані
Наталя в нас була представником
авторського колективу ще раз нагадаю що
ознайомитися з програмами ви можете на
сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
України а також у переліку програм
зазначених в
на сайті інститута модернізації і зміст
освіти і дійсно в умовах сьогодення
організація освітнього процесу повинна
відбуватися з урахуванням безпекової
ситуації за допомогою очної дистанційної
або змішаної форми і у процесі
організації освітньої діяльності в
дистанційному форматі слід звернути
особливу увагу на певні аспекти
діджиталізації освітнього процесу
і зараз Я запрошую до слова доктора
педагогічних наук доцента завідувача
лабораторії дошкільної освіти та
виховання керівника центру раннього
розвитку дитини та дошкільної освіти
інституту проблем виховання Національної
академії педагогічних наук України
Ольгою польську Ольга Дмитрівна
долучатись до нас будь ласка
мікрофончик
ми вас не чуємо мікрофон
Доброго дня шановні колеги
актуальність проблеми яку я сьогодні
спробую для вас актуалізувати вона
обумовлена сучасними реаліями Україна
перебувала в умовах війни сьогодні на
пленарному засіданні нашої конференції
Міністр освіти і науки України Сергій
шкарлет наголосив на двох основних
моментах по-перше це пріоритетність
безпеки дитини в умовах воєнного стану
по-друге це можливість і необхідність
забезпечити доступність освіти для дітей
які перебувають в умовах війни
перебувають за межами України Отже
потребують розв'язання питання
забезпечення доступності і якості
дошкільної освіти в умовах воєнного
стану і саме це зумовлює розробку нових
підходів до організації і технології
реалізації якісної зараз їсти діти
раннього і дошкільного віку суттєвої
допомоги для вирішення цієї проблеми
стане якраз діджиталізація освітньої
діяльності
закладів дошкільної освіти хочу
зауважити що
бюджеталізація є головним трендом
сучасності та радикальним чином
перетворює сутність характеристики
процеси в усіх сфер суспільного життя
Сьогодні заклади освіти не можна
залишитися осторонь цифрової
трансформації цифрові технології стали
невід'ємною частиною нашого
повсякденного буття тому спроба уникнути
їх використання означає втечу від
реальності і при цьому переконана ми
маємо зрозуміти що жити дежуталізація Це
не якийсь явище це глобальна тенденція
максимально вигадав від якої отримують
освітній заклади що повною мірою
наприклад з літерами в області
перетворення освітнього процесу на
основі
освітньої партнерської
освітньої партивської взаємодії
про важливість про важливість
цього процесу для сучасної освіти
цифрові зміни засвідчує прийняття на
рівні держави
концепції цифрової трансформації освіти
і науки на період до 2026 року окрім
того в законах про освіту положення про
дистанційну форму здобуття повної
загальної середньої освіти є положення
які регламентують і
нормативно-регульовуються цифровізацію
освіти на всі планках провідний ідей
принципи виховання дітей молоді в умовах
цифрової реальності сформульовано в
концепції виховання дітей та молоді в
циф просторі яку було підготовлена
національна академії педагогічних наук у
2021 році матеріалами цієї концепції ви
можете познайомитися у вільному доступі
на сайті Національної академії
педагогічних наук України або
на сайті інституту проблем виховання
України
діджуталізація являє собою усвідомлений
підхід до корінного перетворення
будь-яких процесів на основі
використання цифрових технологій зокрема
процесу педагогіки партнерства в
сучасному закладі дошкільної освіти про
що наголошено у новій редакції базового
компонента дошкільної освіти на що
звернули сьогодні увагу під час роботи
нашої секції і вельмишанова Тамара
олександ і Світлана Іванівна і Наталія
Василівна Тобто та теза є переконливою і
я не буду на цьому запобігатися але хочу
ще раз звернути увагу всіх що у зв'язку
з цим Важливим завданням є прискорення
залученості процеси цифрової
трансформації освіти педагогів закладів
дошкільної освіти різних типів і форм
власності Таким чином сучасний заклад
дошкільної освіти має ініціювати нову
глибшу залученість родини до побудови
індивідуальної траєкторії розвитку
дитини цифрове трансформація - це
неминучі процес що відбувається в усьому
світі
високотехнологічне досягнення
впроваджується в наших життя на 100
чинниками трансформації сучасної
освітньої взаємодії є процеси
глобалізації біжуталізації і
конвергенції що значною мірою визначають
життя сучасної особистості та
суспільства 21 статті цифрової
трансформації розуміємо процес
диджисталізації що спрощує доступ до
інформації поняття діджиталізація на
хлопця тлумачить як способи проведення
будь-якого різного виду інформації у
цифрову форму з використанням цифрових
технологій
сутність ними характеристиками цифрових
технологій мобільний з доступність
безкоштовне зберігання та використання
інформації
незалежна від місця
знаходження відсутність необхідності
оновлення та встановлення програмного
забезпечення Таким чином одними
звикликів більш реалізованого
суспільства є готовність педагога до
цифрової трансформації освітнього
процесу проектування індивід
індивідуальної траєкторії розвитку
дитини
і забезпечення партнерства між усіма
учасниками освітньої діяльності дітьми
педагогами і батьками Проте зараз
Україна знову ж таки нагадуємо не
забуваємо ми всі про це пам'ятаємо бо це
наша реальність перебуває в умовах
запровадження
воєнного стану і сьогодні
Мої колеги Ольга Геннадіївна Наталія
Василівна говорили про і Світлана
Іванівна говорили про форми здобуття
дошкільної освіти і завдяки науковцям
завдяки роботі інститут модернізації
змісту освіти державної установи
інститут розвитку освіти
розроблена певний методичний супровід
який розміщено в вільному доступі на
сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки у вільному
доступі але хочу заува
що саме ці реалії вони не зважаючи на
той матеріал який
є він є проблема теоретично
обґрунтування закономірності принципів
освіти навчання і виховання дітей
раннього та дошкільного віку з
використанням якраз потенціалу цифрового
освітнє виховного середовища закладу
дошкільної освіти розробки і їх тут
спільного застосування відповідного
науково-методичного забезпечення зокрема
і певних цифрових ресурсів з метою
підвищення якості освітнього процесу
єдності зусиль і у партнерських
взаємодії дітей педагогів Отже Дозвольте
мені запропонувати ваші вази шляхи
забезпечення доступності якості
дошкільної освіти в умовах воєнного
стану через діджиталізацію освітнього
процесу по-перше
має бути орієнтир на здобувачів
дошкільної освіти на забезпечення
всебічного розвитку дитини дошкільного
віку набуття нежиттєвого соціального
досвіду А для цього ми з вами Маємо
знайти відповідь на запитання дитина
дошкільного віку першу черговому
просторі що це об'єктивна реальність чи
необхідність до причин занурення дитини
дошкільного віку цифровий простір
відносимо повсюдно допитливість високий
рівень пізнавальної активності потребу
яскравих зовнішніх вражень потребу у
спілкуванні потреби у грі перевагами
раннього занурення
дошкільниках цифрової простір є раннє
введення дитині в інформаційно-цифрове
світ що сприяє розширення кола і
інтересів забезпечує розвиток цієї
спрямованості кмітливості стимулює
розвиток пізнавальних здібностей та уяви
що має виховну і освітню
спрямованість шляхами безпечного
занурення дошкільника у цифровий простір
є розуміння захисту дітей як спільної
відповідальності всіх зацікавлених
сторін формування основ цифрової
грамотності збереження здоров'я дитини у
цифровому просторі
по-друге одним із викликів
бюджеталізована суспільства є готовність
педагога до цифрової трансформації
освітнього процесу проектування
індивідуальної траєкторії розвитку
дитини та організації сучасного процесу
педагогіки партнерства між дітьми та
педагогами педагогами та батьками
сучасні заклади дошкільної освіти
потребують педагогічних працівників
здатних орієнтуватися в цифровому
просторі отримувати дані та оперувати
ними відповідно до власних потреб і
вимог сучасного суспільства
переконане що
професійне документовведення має бути
активізований з якою вивільне часу для
ефективної організації педагогічної
праці а це права компетентність
вихователів є умовою їхньої швидкої
орієнтації у цукровому просторі участі в
українському та міжнародному
професійному співробітництві одне з
головних завдань дошкільної освіти в
умовах розвитку цифрового суспільства це
навчити вихователів використовувати
сучасні цифрові технології зв'язки тим
виникає проблема
прискорення або підвищення їхньої
підготовки в галузі цифрових технологій
і відповідно оснащення закладів
дошкільної освіти сучасної комп'ютерної
техніки педагогічними програмними
засобами електронними підручниками
тощо Отже наступне третє те створення
цифрового освітньо-виховного середовища
закладу дошкільної освіти
яке слугуватиме об'єднання суб'єктів
освітньої діяльності педагогів закладів
дошкільної освіти батьків дітей раннього
дошкільного віку спеціалістів
державних служб системи освіти
спеціаліста гормони і так далі І так
далі щодо забезпечення єдиного простору
для комунікації та обміну інформацією
розуміння
після того якісного цифрового освітнього
контенту та легкого доступу до
навчального матеріалу зокрема
електронного дидактичного матеріалу про
який говорила Наталія Василівна як
освітнього харного ресурсу об'єкти
суб'єктами освітньої діяльності для
забезпечення здобуття дітьми зазначено у
віку їх розвитку і виховання
цифрове освітнє виховне середовище
закладу освіту утворюють
матеріально-технічне
психолого-педагогічне дидактичне
комунікативне забезпечення освітнього
процесу що включає засоби навчання
виховання які базуються на нових
цифровий та інформаційна комунікаційних
технологіях навчання та меховій
інформації яка якраз сприяє формуванню
соціально важливих якостей усіх
суб'єктів
освітньої діяльності
з метою створення цифрового освітнього
виховного середовища закладу дошкільної
освіти ви мали можливість
місця на слайді самостійно я не буду на
цьому зупинятися четверте зауважую
підкреслюю що проблема організації
процесу педагогіки партнерства з
батьками полягає в тому що сили своєї
дані такої більшість з них не мають
можливості бути
учасниками
педагогічного процесу обрати участь в
управлінні впливати на роботу освітнього
закладу тому потрібні механізми які
дозволять здійснювати оперативно
взаємодію з батьками забезпечувати
рівноправність партнерства між закладами
освіти і сім'ї головним завданням
педагогіки-партнерства вважаємо
перехідна якісно новий рівень побудова
міжособистісної взаємодії між учасниками
освітнього процесу зокрема в
використанні можливостей цифрових
технологій як інструмент педагогіки
партнерства використання можливостей
цифрових технологій для мережевої
взаємодії з батьками є життєво
необхідним що наприклад якраз здійснити
оперативний обмін інформацією проводити
консультації з різних питань бути
рівноправними партнерами таким чином щоб
налагодити контакт батькам І зробити
взаємодію конструктивною надати реально
допомогу необхідні активні форми
взаємодії про Яких батьків зможуть
спостерігати за відмінною відстежувати
її досягнете
радіти тішитися від спілкування з
дитиною і можливості долучити для до
цього процесу на нашу думку основними
напрямами зокрема мережевої педагогіки
партнерства закладу дошкільної освіти і
цінні є інформування Просвіта
консультування навчання спільна
діяльність
сучасним і цікавим трендом організації
процесу взаємодії є засобів комунікації
що набули
ознак мобільності та цифрових технологій
урізноманітних соціальних мережах
телеграм Instagram Viber
і так далі але Хочу наголосити що
залишається актуальним і перспективним
напрямом у забезпеченні освіти розвитку
і виховання дітей засобами цифрового
освітньої духовного середовища саме
колаборація педагогів і батьків з
усвідомленням їх особливої
відповідальності за дах здоров'я дітей
безпечно занурення у цифровий простір і
надання їм основ цифрової
грамотності переконана що запропоновано
чотири
сходинки щодо впровадження
діджуталізації освітньої діяльності
закладу дошкільної освіти по-перше
дозволять забезпечити доступність
[музика]
якість дошкільної освіти а по-друге
оптимізувати процес взагалі
дежуталізації освітньої галузі Дякую вам
за увагу
щиро вдячна Ольга Дмитрівна за таку
чудову вашу розповідь промову і за
настанови якими ви поділилися
партнерська взаємодія провідний принцип
діяльності Міністерства освіти і науки
України один із прикладів такого
партнерства є плідна співпраця із далеко
foundtion що сприяє розвитку якості
освіти через всебічний розвиток дитини
зокрема компетентностей необхідних для
навчання упродовж життя та становлення
педагога василітатора який прагне
відійти і від педагогіки копіювання
шаблонування практики однієї правильної
відповіді та нав'язування свого бачення
дитини в основі був взаємодії дорослого
і дитини покладено підхід навчання через
гру слово надаю керівниці освітніх
ініціатив залив foundation в Україні
Оксані Ромі пані Оксана будь ласка вам
слово дякую пані Світлана за таку чудову
вступну частину і вітання усім незламним
нескореним освітянам України відміною
особливістю цьогорічної серпневої
конференції є те що з одного боку це
захід з болем але нескореної вірою в
очах і в терцях а з іншого боку це наше
нестримне бажання докласти в десятеро
більше зусиль для того щоб не тільки
утримати напрацьоване роками а й навпаки
наважитися на рішення про які можливо за
інших обставин у мирний час і не
подумали можна будь ласка тільки вивести
відповідну презентацію Lego foundtion
наступна мала бути і історична доба і
реалії в яких ми сьогодні навігаємо
навігує українська система освіти
безперечно може дати відлік проривним
рішенням квантовим стрибкам але водночас
і поглибити всі ті реформи всі ті
починання які були розпочаті Звісно це
потребує об'єднання зусиль держави
громадського сектору міжнародних
партнерів батьківської спільноти навколо
вектору і траєкторії руху освіти України
її відновлення розбудови і безперечно
інновації сьогодні дуже багато Ми чуємо
про інновації Тому це є невід'ємною
частиною будь-якої кризової ситуації яку
проходять країни увесь світ сьогодні
пристрій не відслідковує події в Україні
але за майже півроку війни ключовими
ративом який ми чуємо у світовій
спільноті є те що на противагу усім
іншим кризам пов'язаним з війнами
України і наша система освіти стоїть не
здається рухає розпочаті реформи і
відкрита до нових проєктів Та ініціатив
ось лише декілька посилань якщо
з'являться зараз на екрані до цих
наративів ми бачимо у світових медіах
про те що говорять система освіти
України витримує виклики війни ми бачимо
наратив про те що системі освіти вдалося
перебудувати це відповідно до потреб
воєнного часу
ми бачимо наратив про те що мільйони
дітей продовжують навчання і розвиток
супереч війни і це слово всупереч стає
тим завдяки якому ми рухаємося і
рухаємось не тільки в рамках
гуманітарних потреб як те правило як ти
правило відбувається вкризових ситуаціях
в рамках нашої
добре надайте мені доступ
[музика]
так
зараз спробуємо
так і хочу повернутися до тих наративів
які про які я говорила які на сьогодні є
у світовій спільноті ось про що пишуть
світові медіа про українського світу ми
рухаємося наші діти продовжують навчання
продовжують розвиток тому що
відбувається навколо І сьогодні це слово
всупереч стає тим завдяки якому ми як
освіта України можемо стати не тільки
країною яка вистояла а країною яка стане
успішним кейсом відбудови і інновацій На
світовій арені тому сьогоднішні
гуманітарний компонент має бути не
окремою лінією підтримки освіти а
органічно вплетеним у цілісну Вітю
поступу освіти саме тому фундація Lego
маючи вже Понад 12 років співпраці з
українським міністерством освіти і науки
України наразі продовжує реалізацію
проєктів у дошкіллі в початковій базовій
школі а також в системі післядипломної
педагогічної освіти і вищої освіти з
метою укорінення ідей ігрового і
діяльністьного навчання у свідомості і
практиках кожного педагога як міжнародна
інституція яка має вже вибудовану
співпрацю з міністерством освіти
наскрізну співпрацю із освітою України
Ми продовжуємо всі ті проекти які були
розпочаті але поглиблюємо і підсилюємо
ці проекти гуманітарним компонентом те
що наразі є найбільш актуальним для
дошкілля це проєкт сприяння освіти цей
проєкт наразі є в 300 закладах
дошкільної освіти 15 областей України
він буде продовжений до цього проекту
будуть додаватися нові заклади
дошкільної освіти в інших областях
України і буде далі продовжено
професійний розвиток і систематичне
методична підтримка педагогів але окрім
цього
ми маємо пам'ятати що сьогодні той зміст
і ті ресурси які ми пропонуємо педагогам
має набувати кардинально іншого змісту
що мається на увазі це зміст має бути
ресурсним підтримуючим для дітей для
їхніх родин але також для самих
педагогів Тому ці заклади які наразі є в
проекті будуть забезпечені технічними
засобами навчання і ми в Україні будемо
будемо
пропонувати нову програму програму
соціальної емоційного розвитку дітей
веселі друзі і Пеппа це програма яка
містить і діджуталізований компонент яка
містить також компонент
який можна яким можна поділитися
педагогами це набори іграшок які будуть
залучені до взаємодії з дітьми методичні
рекомендації для педагогів протягом
22-23 років та програма буде
пілотуватися проектних закладах а далі
вона стане доступною для усіх закладів
освіти
Окрім цього дуже важливо на сьогодні є
забезпечити підтримку дітей і родин але
передусім також подбати про ресурс самих
педагогів про вас педагоги про те щоб ви
володіли інструментами механізмами і
способами яким чином потурбуватися про
власний психологічний стан тому
найближчому майбутньому ми пропонуємо
курс який буде реалізований спільно з
інститутами післядипломної освіти це
курс психосоціальної підтримки дітей та
педагогів закладів дошкільної та
загальної середньої освіти благополучать
педагогів та дітей дієві інструменти та
практики
Цей курс буде зреалізований через
інститути післядипломної освіти
розроблені спільно Lego fountation та
шведські організації mhps колаборації
якщо ми рухаємося далі сьогодні вже
неодноразово згадували про марафон Та
який триває на підтримку реалізації
державного стандарту
дошкільної освіти за qr-кодом який зараз
ви бачите на екрані можете переглянути
ту трансляцію яка сформувалася Минулого
тижня і це трансляція є таким своєрідним
вступом кізером до того великого курсу
який я щойно анонсувала
а саме це вебінар гра як інструмент
підтримки благополуччя дітей сьогодні
педагогам надзвичайно важливо мати в
своєму арсеналі надзвичайно багато
ресурсів курсів матеріалів які
допоможуть набігувати в реаліях
невизначеності не певності і того не
Мирного часу в який ми проживаємо тому
ось Іще один з ресурсів - це
онлайн-курси які можна пройти на
платформі Future вони доступні зараз за
qr-кодом або так само їх можна буде
знайти у матеріалах конференції
далі Які ресурси матеріали ми ще
пропонуємо ми пропонуємо один із
ресурсів - це збірка ігрових активностей
націлених на формування ключових навичок
для фізичного когнітивного соціального
емоційного розвитку дітей від
всесвітньої організації Рай також за
розходу можна знайти і ігрові онлайн
взаємодії для дошкільнят які також
знаходяться на сайті Міністерства освіти
і науки України будь ласка користуйтеся
Ми дуже сподіваємося що це стане такою
вам
потрібною допомогою у
сьогоднішній реальності але ми розуміємо
що частина дітей знаходиться не тільки в
Україні і поза її меж тому дуже важливо
підтримати наших дітей і наших педагогів
які знаходяться в сусідніх країнах або
далеко-далеко за океаном тому фундації
Lego спільно і афінською компанією був
розроблений додаток який називається
мукамера лінгваев для того щоб допомогти
дітям опановувати мовами зокрема
англійською французькою іспанською
шведською норвезькою іспанською данської
китайською арабською з якою метою щоб
діти швидше могли інтегруватися і
адаптуватися в тому соціумі в якому вони
зараз проживають цей застосунок можна
завантажити з Apple Store або Google
Play Абсолютно безкоштовно в будь-якій
країні світу і головне що дітям не
обов'язково знати букви цифри вміти
читати чи писати весь контент весь вміст
вибудуваний в ігровому форматі
і те що ми також анонсуємо це програма
парціальна програма розвитку дитини від
2 до 6 років наразі вона доступна для
педагогів які працюють поза межами
України в нашими дітьми в колективних
центрах в центрах гри і розвитку в
закладах дошкільної освіти інших країн
світу Ця програма доступна для закладів
з 300 закладів які є учасниками проекту
в рамках нашого проекту і сподіваємось
на найближчим часом та недоступною для
усіх педагогів України
І що дуже важливо те що ті ідеї які
складаються пропагує в Україні Ми ні в
якому разі не Залишаємо тільки нашими
ідеями нашими думками нашими
напрацюваннями увесь твій досвід ми
поступово поширюємо через інститути
післядипломної освіти і якщо на сайтах
ваших регіональних інститутів ось
зокрема тих які вказані на екрані ви
будете бачити спецкурт в оголошеннях
педагогіка гри у закладі дошкільної
освіти це така вступна частина до тієї
програми яку я щойно анонсувала можете
записуватися реєструватися і проходити
всі курси і те що наразі відбувається у
дошкіллі України насправді і вірогідно
Та не одним з унікальних сестів
підтримки розбудови системи освіти це
може стати ресурсом для багатьох інших
країн які потребують чи потребуватимуть
відновлення освітніх систем на
концептуальному рівні цей кейс провів і
незламність про Партнерство і співпрацю
провізію і її реалізацію про продовження
розпо увагу і про ініціювання нового про
каталізацію потрібного і відмови від
усього зайвого про прийняття вкрай
складних але довготривалій перспективі
необхідних рішень і завершуючи сесію
сьогодні з нашими незламними освітянами
хочу нам запропонувати дати відповідь на
одне запитання мій ресурс сьогодні у
подумайте В чому ваш ресурс пам'ятайте
Повертайтеся до нього і звертатися до
нього і як би складно нам сьогодні не
було ми не самі нас багато тисяч це
багатотисячна спільнота і в цьому наша
сила тож крилами на крилах і під крилами
до нового навчального року Дякуємо пані
Оксана щира вам Дякуємо за надихаючу
промову Щиро дякуємо команді за Lego
foundation за ту справу яку ви робите ми
відчуваємо той ресурс який ви подаєте
українському дошкіллю Щиро дякуємо що не
залишаєтеся осторонь і щиро дяку тому що
всі інновації з доведеної ефективністю
доводити кожен куточок кожен заклад
дошкільної освіти Дякуємо за вашу
партнерську взаємодію А я ще хочу
нагадати що на сайті Міністерства освіти
і науки України у рубриці сучасне
дошкілля під крилами захисту є окрема
рубрика яка присвячена
доробкам про які щойно говорила пані
Оксана рубрика під назвою зе Lego
foundation Дорогі колеги долучайтеся
неймовірно цікаві матеріали неймовірно
інноваційні їх можна використовувати як
у дистанційному форматі так і під час
почної форми навчання Дякуємо Lego
foundation сподіваємось на подальшому
плідно співпраця
і Дорогі колеги дійсно пані Оксана
сказала про те що ми не одні і кожен
громадянин України на сьогодні докладає
максимум зусиль задля Перемоги саме
сьогодні наша єдність та патріотична
налаштованість є важливим кроком до
такого очікуваного миру у незалежній
Україні тож друзі зараз до віртуальної
подорожі найкращою країною славетною
Україною нас запрошують колеги з міста
Запоріжжя і
кандидат педагогічних наук доцент
кафедри дошкільної освіти Запорізького
обласного інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти Людмила Шульга Та
директор закладу дошкільної освіти номер
100 в гармонія міста Запоріжжя пані
Наталя канцедал Дорогі колеги
долучайтесь дуже хочемо подорожувати
Україною
Дякую Пані Ольго за
представлення наше да спочатку Ми
подорожуємо нашими ресурсами кафедрою
дошкільної освіти і потім я передам
слово пані Наталі Шановні колеги вас
вітає Запорізька область І дійсно
справжніми крилами захисту дошкільної
освіти сьогодні є така професійна
підтримка педагогів Ми дуже коротко
представляємо досвід кафедри дошкільної
освіти Запорізького інституту
післядипломної освіти який суттєво
допомагає вирішувати проблеми сьогодення
а сучасні виклики які стоять сьогодні
перед освітою і пандемія і
повномасштабна війна в Україні вони не
просто актуалізують а навіть виступають
такими потужними каталізаторами
інформатизації освіти оскільки саме
цифрові технології надають можливість
отримати освітні послуги Як дорослим так
і дітям і Враховуючи те що більшість
закладів дошкільної освіти Запорізької
області сьогодні знаходиться в зоні
бойових дій і під окупацією і великий
відсоток педагогів і дітей вимушено
евакувалися за межі регіону то єдиною
опцією для взаємодії сьогодні виступає в
дистанційний зв'язок який забезпечує і
безперервність освіти і завдяки
інформаційним технологіям є можливість
вирішувати питання щодо забезпечення її
ефективності і якості і на наступному
слайді можна побачити що сьогодні у
педагогів Запорізької області є
можливість отримувати
дистанційну освіту і підвищувати фахову
майстерність за допомогою як проходження
курсів підвищення кваліфікації на
платформі модул а також у міжкурсовий
період на освітньому середовищі кафедри
дошкільної освіти Таким чином педагог
після проходження курсів не втрачає
зв'язок з післядипломною освітою і є
активним учасником освітніх заходів і
наступний слайд ілюструє дистанційну
систему підвищення кваліфікації на
платформі Moodle за освіт програмами для
педагогів повний перехід такий
післядипломної педагогічної освіти у
дистанційний формат сприяв значному
підвищенню рівню цифрової компетентності
і викладачів і здобувачів освіти а з
іншого боку надав можливість виявити і
вирішити проблеми у забезпеченні якості
освітнього процесу завдяки таким фаховим
із різних освітніх напрямів
забезпечується теоретичний навіть
практична підготовка в дистанційних
умовах і приділяється значна увага
практичному опануванню педагогічних
технік та інструментів ігрових та
діяльнісних підходів у розвитку дітей
дошкільного віку фахові модулі
містять 32 спецкуси це колеги 4-5
спецкурси на кожну програму і все це
спрямовано на вдосконалення саме оцього
технологічного складника професійної
компетентності і на цій же платформі
також пропонується система тренінгів на
між важливий період і наступному слайді
представлено
як питання оцієї ефективності якості
освіти і професійного розвитку педагогу
міжксовий період вирішується за
допомогою
інформаційно-освітнього середовища
розбудованого з 2015 року з метою такої
інформаційної підтримки освітнього
процесу із забезпечення умов щодо
професійного розвитку педагогів закладів
дошкільної освіти Запорізькій області і
сьогодні
Шановні колеги
інформаційно-освітнє середовище являє
собою системно організовану сукупність
веб-ресурсів орієнтовано на задоволення
потреб у підвищенні рівня
професіоналізму педагогів і складається
з 28 пов'язаних із сайтом кафедри
дошкільної освіти веб-присусів частину з
них Тут продемонстровано на слайді і
їхня цінність полягає в тому що вони
складають великий інформаційний банк
педагогічного досвіду закладів
дошкільної освіти інноваційних практик
педагогів Запорізької області а також
науково-методичних здобутків науковців
як кафедри так і і наших партнерів і
завдяки сайту Новин який є по суті таким
хронологічним Навігатором можна з 2015
року відтворити всі заходи з усіма
представленими на них матеріалами на
наступному слайді ми можемо побачити як
сайт кдо також зорієнтовує педагога в
отриманні інформації щодо
науково-методичної діяльності і кожен
Аватар відкриває доступ до переліку
заходів розміщених за роками з
посиланням так наприклад з правил ми
бачимо як розкривається посилання
творних груп дати засідань з посиланням
де можна отримати напрацьований
практиками матеріал з проблемної теми і
в наступному слайді показано як
справжньою
педагогічних здобутків освітясних
фестивалів методист року Україна рідний
край перлинки Запорізького краю
Технопарк художньо-педагогічних ідей і
ці Саме ці фестивалі і сайти висвітлюють
матеріали учасників заключних етапів з
2015 року долучають до педагогічного
досвіду до парціальних програм до
перспективного і календарного планування
до методичних здобутків навчальних
презентацій відео дидактичних матеріалів
і тощо і саме погляньте будь ласка
ціннісним набуттям справи Ви бачите
скріншоти кафедри дошкільної освіти став
би присуд з Технопарк
художньо-педагогічних ідей із базою
педагогічною новакики-практики в
Запорізької області за трьома
номінаціями художня креативність коли
картина оживає і цьогоріч додався її ще
додалася додалась номінація арт-проєкти
ресурс містить навчально сонячні
комплекси запровадження різноманітних
педагогічних арт-технологій зі
сприйняття творів мистецтва синтезу
мистецтв запровадження художніх технік
із використанням нетрадиційних
матеріалів і зручним у використанні
розроблених комплексів є наявність
авторського короткого відео за допомогою
якого педагог може легко сам опанувати
будь-яку художню техніку і використати
її в навчанні дітей а також за допомогою
відео долучити до перегляду творчої
інтерпретації твору живопису знаєте
сьогодні технологічний парки це
своєрідна така спільнота творчих
педагогів це віртуальна творча група до
якої входять за власну ініціативою
презентують власні мистецькі проєкти
художні техніки технології і все це
доступно інформативно креативно
позитивно і естетично на сьогоднішній
день Технопарк представляє найбільший
освітній банк в інтернеті з розробленою
системою відео можна використання
нетрадиційних технік зображення
мистецького напряму і Шановні колеги
лише за перший рік 2019 було
опубліковано понад 57 видів
зображувальної техніки серед яких як
відомі художні техніки так і
нетрадиційні це є ресурс надихає на
художню творчість або мовах викликів
сьогодення це справжні крила і крила
захисту і крила натхнення для педагогів
дітей і батьків і в наступному слайді Ми
представляємо мапу педагогічної
творчості та інноватики закладів
дошкільної освіти Запорізької області
мапа інтерактивна Вона знаходиться на
домашній сторінці сайту кафедри
дошкільної освіти і дозволяє за різними
освітніми напрямами долучитися до
творчих здобутків практиків кожний
напрям має свій символ у кружечку
натискаючи на нього на мапі
розкриваються матеріали досвіду згідно з
районом області і більш детально на
наступному слайді представлено оці школі
популяризації чи демонстрації досвіду
матеріали презентовані або форми опису
еппд або текою з матеріалами досвіду в
якій поряд із описом є постер досвіду
додатки відео презентації також
педагогічна творчість представлена у
відео в освітніх проєктах парціальних
програмах методичному забезпеченню до
цих програм публікаціях з досвіду роботи
для кафедри дошкільної освіти
педагогічна творчість практиків є
справжньою професійною цінністю і ми
вбачаємо свою роль у популяризації цієї
творчості і точно знаємо що визначення
результатів творчості педагогів як на
рівні області І тим паче на рівні
України Це для наших педагогів є
справжньою винагородою і на наступному
слайді представлено в такому дуже
стиснутому вигляді систему внутрішньої
навігації по вітчизняними ресурсом які
дозволяють наш сучасному педагогу
долучитися швидко достатньо моно
інституту психології вищих навчальних
закладів інституту післядипломної освіти
асоціації працівників дошкільної освіти
видавництв дитячих клубів каналів в
Ютубі і таке інше Да і останній слайд в
якому представлена підтримка педагогів
під час воєнного стану з актуальною
інформацією
та нещодавно створений такий онлайн
порадник для отримання педагогами
закладів дошкільної освіти Запорізької
області консультації від працівників
кафедри Шановні колеги наша діяльність у
напрямі використання інформаційних
технологій доводить що
інформаційно-освітнє середовище в
сьогоденних умовах забезпечує педагога і
інформаційної підтримкою допомагає
здійснювати самоосвіту у володівати
новими компетентностями А ще дозволяє
розкрити власний потенціал і безумовно
надихає не педагогічну творчість і
зрощує бажання спільно створювати
щасливе майбутнє навіть в умовах
викликах сього питання Дякую за увагу і
задоволенням передаю слово своїй
коліжанці директору закладу дошкільної
освіти 100 гармонія міста Запоріжжя
канцелял Наталії Володимирівні яка
продемонструє освітній творчий продукт
із використанням інформаційних
технологій будь ласка
Доброго дня шановні колеги
моя презентація
закладушкільної освіти номер 100
я вас рада вітати вас вітаю заклад
дошкільної освіти номер 100 гармонія
міста Запоріжжя і Я сьогодні хочу
ознайомити вас сучасним іноваційним
інтерактивним проектом дітям про Україну
даний проект - це авторська народка
педагогічного колективу заклади
дошкільної освіти № 100 гармонія
наступний слайд
метою даного проекту є ознайомлення
дітей з областями нашої країни з
визначними подіями пам'ятками
архітектури та культурно-доповного
мистецтва
даний проект складається нібито з двох
частин Перша частина - це
виготовлення дитячої мапи України друга
частина - це організація віртуальних
подорожей країни
так у грудні 2021 року скляному фо є здо
номер 100 гармонія з'являється велика
дитяча мапа України мальовнича дитяча
мапа - це детальна мапа яка відображає
всі 25 областей включаючи автономну
Республіку Крим обласні центри та
історичні місця України
розрахована ця мапа для дітей
молодшого шкільного віку та дошкільного
віку тому що слід для дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами на мапі подані
столиці всі обласні центри державні
символи України
яскравими малюнками доступні
візуалізаційні форми показана природу
господарську діяльність
історико-культурний та природа заповідні
об'єкти а також визначні місця Мама
знайомить дітей з нашою країною загалом
та особливостями її окремих регіонів
мапа настінного формату матова ламінація
виготовлена з високоякісного цупкого
матеріалу надійна прикріплена до стіни
що забезпечує додаткову зручність по
використанню розмір даної мапи 2 на 3
метри контур карти ефектна та естетична
підсвічує приємна для ока
ілюмінація яка керується пультом
наступний слайд
іноваційність даної технології полягає у
використанні
інформаційно-комунікативних технологіях
а саме
кожна з 25 областей України має власник
qr-код зчитавши який мобільним пристроєм
дитина разом з дорослим зможе
подорожувати Україною дізнається про
видатних людей промисловість цікаві
факти кожного регіону зараз до вашої
уваги є qr-коди ви можете зараз навести
камеру свого мобільного пристрою і ви
потрапите вже до подорожей все детальна
інформація є доступною захоплююче
розміщена в кольорових слайдах і формує
необхідні компетенції сприяє розвитку
іноваційні культури особистості доречне
використання мобільних пристроїв
особливо актуальне в умовах модернізації
змісту освіти через демонстрацію та
власну роботу на інтерактивний дошці з
ноутбуком Smart TV прослуховуванням
через навушники та інше з метою
спеціалізація пам'яті та розумових
процесів дітей під час роботи з картою
педагог вдала поєднує мультимедійні
засоби навчання тексти аудіо малюнки
анімація інтерактивні завдання створені
у формі гри та візуалізацію цей сприяє
розвитку одночасно декілька аналізаторів
а значить поліпшення уваги мислення
мовлення пам'яті тощо
фундаментом роботи з мапою є
мультисенсорний підхід що зосереджується
у слуховому візуальному маніпуляційному
сприйняття зміст і матеріалу кожного дня
діти бачать та роздивляються маком
завдяки яскравим візуалізаційним
ілюстраціям та
інформаційно-комп'ютерним технологіям
знайомства з рідним краєм є захопливим
та пізнавальним сприяє знайомству із
кожної областю культура українського
народу та економіка позитивно впливає на
розвиток українська мовлення
логічного мислення пам'яті фантазії уяви
тощо у процесі виконання завдання дитина
вчитимусь розповідати про Україну як про
свою батьківщину
розпізнавати державні і народні символи
шанобливе ставитись до них а значить
вчитися бути патріотом своєї країни
наступний слайд будь ласка
з даним проектом можливо ознайомитись на
сайті нашого закладу
зараз до вашої уваги скріншот нашого
сайту і можливо побачити ми відокремили
проект дітям про Україну це активна
така вкладочка якщо ви натиснетесь то ви
потрапите саме до цього проекту
наступний слайд
цікаве те що дана карта Якщо ви
потрапите на наш сайт вона є
інтерактивною і щоб стала мапа
інтерактивного вам достатньо
доторкнутися як показана Зелена стрічка
наступний слайд
кожній області якщо ви придивитесь
уважно то можливо побачити два кружечки
це жовте та сині кружечки
Я спочатку не
бачимо а якщо придивимось уважно то ми
їх побачимо на цій карті
наступне слайд якщо ви доторкнетесь до
жовтого кружечку то перед вами
відкривається презентація огляд цієї
області з якою ви зараз знаходитесь
наступний слайд якщо ви
доторкаєтесь до синього кружечка
то вас запрошує наша педагогіння
екскурсовод Альона Супрун до відеоогляду
і ознайомить вас з цікавинками даної
області
наступний слайд всі відеоогляди
розміщені на нашому власному каналі
YouTube канал гармонія який зараз
скріншот якого ми зараз вам пропонуємо
роздивитися
наступний слайд
дитяча мапа з’явилась в нашому закладі
наприкінці грудня 2021 року А в червні
2022 року було
закінчено додаток до цієї карти і Ми
сподіваємось що даний проект стане
поштовхом для вас шановні колеги для
мандрування нашої країни України у
будь-який зручний для вас час і як можна
не частіше Розповідайте дітям про нашу
країну Україну і все буде Україна Слава
Україні
Героям слава Дорогі колеги дякуємо вам
за ваш виступ за унікальну роботу і
творчу працю ваших колективів дійсно
Україна єдина Україна найкраща і про
нашу країну мають знати всі про те що
вони зламані про те що українці
непереможні і про те що Україна
у серці кожного з нас і Дякуємо що ви
популяризуєте свої творчі проекти хочу
нагадати нашим глядачам що за
результатами нашої конференції всі
матеріали виступів будуть розміщені на
сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
України української інституту розвитку
освіти і ви можете обов'язково
ознайомитися з цими матеріалами тому що
ви щойно не залишили байдужими наших
глядачів всі вам дякую за те що ви
дозволили побувати в кожному куточку
України
Дякуємо і мандруємо далі сьогодні Ми
піднімаємо всі актуальні питання і одним
із актуальних питань нашого сьогодення -
це питання психологічного супроводу
питання того як у під час війни
в закладах освіти працювати нашим
педагогічним працівникам які ми
навичками володіти Як допомогти дитині
подолати тривожність панічні атаки як
переключити увагу дитини під час такого
кризового стану і наразі Ми маємо
унікальну можливість поспілкуватися з
нашими колегами
практичними психологами саме з питання
психологічної підтримки учасників
освітнього процесу у закладах дошкільної
освіти і запрошую зараз до виступу
кандидата психологічних наук завідуючи
відділом освіти дітей з порушеннями зору
інститути спеціальної педагогіки імені
Миколи ярмаченка Національної академії
педагогічних наук України Тетяну
Костенко пані Тетяна долучайтесь до нас
будь ласка
Доброго дня колеги друзі всі хто нас
зараз дивиться Ми з України продовжуючи
сьогоднішню важливу тему зупинимося
детально на психологічний підтримці
учасників освітнього процесу в закладах
дошкільної освіти я розумію нашу
обмеженість у часі тому я наставлю
просто ключові акценти а як уже сказала
пані Ольга детально ви можете
ознайомитися з презентацією на сайті
будь ласка наступний слайд Отже якщо ми
згадаємо що ж таке психологічна
підтримка зараз це дуже вживане слово це
певна система так
соціально-психологічних та
психолого-педагогічних способів і
методів допомоги собі та іншим з метою
оптимізації психоемоційного стану Ми вже
всі ознайомлені з методичними
рекомендаціями так щодо здійснення
освітньої діяльності у дошкільній освіті
і ми знаємо вже що заклади дошкільної
освіти мають стати не лише осередками
які дають змогу дітям отримати завжди не
лише знання та практичні вміння а й
мають стати психолого-педагогічної
підтримкою для всіх учасників освітнього
процесу наступний слайд
якщо подивимося на такі схематичні
будиночки то ми вже для себе розуміємо
що психологічна підтримка потрібна усім
в першу чергу це дітям фахівцям які
працюють у закладі дошкільної освіти та
батькам наступний слайд і ми розуміємо
що потрібно Скажімо так схематично за
принципом рюкзачка у нас уже стало так
звично називати це так Або ж тривожна
валізка і ще називають
попередньо ми бачимо що у кожного в
дорослого свій колір так у дитини свій
колір рюкзачка Ну і я за цим принципом
спробувала сформувати Так ці рюкзачки ми
бачимо що жовтенькі це для дитини
синенькі для батьків зелений Або ж
салатовий для адміністрації та для
фахівців червоний попередньо вже колеги
говорили що сучасний заклад має уже
обладнане бомбослове ще так і все саме
для того щоб діти почувалися у безпеці
державні заклади поки що потребують
знову ж таки
детального вивчення питання та
забезпечення безпеки тому ми з вами
зараз маємо можливість подбати про
психологічну безпеку та підтримку
наступний слайд тому що зараз
вирішується багато
багатьох сім'ях питання чи підуть діти
взагалі в закладишкільної освіти Чи вони
виберу дистанційну освіту будуть
навчатися онлайн але все ж таки
наскільки я спілкуюся з батьками то вони
хочуть віддати дітей заклади дошкільної
освіти Але попередньо якщо ми прямуємо
закладу так що у нас в душі У нас є
певний страх тривога сумніви відповідні
певні фізичні
реакції ми можемо відчувати пару
психологічну підтримку так її хочуть
отримати батьки діти
птахівці і в чергу адміністрація
наступний слайд тому що для
адміністрації
і це відповідає щоби всі були безпеці
щоби були забезпечені так і зараз можете
взяти аркуш паперу олівець ручку
трішечки будемо практично працювати Тому
що це такі
наприклад що потрібно дітям дітям
потрібні Обійми відчуття що
важливо батькам переходимо так до
наступної колоночки це підтримка це
впевненість у тому що їхня дитина в
безпеці це психологічний зв'язок довіра
до простору для фахівців важливо Це
знання як діяти ті чи іншій ситуації Це
добре що у нас є сформована уже папка
для того якщо буде небезпечна ситуація
але інколи ми Не встигаємо
у закладі дошкільної освіти маємо швидко
реагувати на будь-яку небезпеку так і
для адміністрації це можливість створити
безпечне місце для всіх учасників
освітнього процесу вчасне реагування на
небес хочу цей рядочок для себе щоб ви
знали як ви можете допомогти собі та
іншим учасникам процесу так наступний
слайд будь ласка
Отже якщо ми говоримо так про валізки
для адміністрації та фахівців що з собою
треба взяти зараз дуже популярне таке
поняття термін резоліантність Так ми
говоримо про
стресостійкість фахівців тому що діти
зчитують Вони дуже відчувають як
налаштовані дорослі чи справляться вони
з ситуацією Тому нам важливо подбати про
себе в першу чергу щоб ми могли
допомогти дітям захистити їх надати їм
психологічну підтримку тому прості
правила Пам'ятайте про сенс
особистісність мистецтва так згадайте
коли вам дуже важко здається що ви
нічого не можете вже зараз діяти як ви
прийшли до професії педагога чому
вибрали саме цю професію запишіть
коротенько десь на аркуші паперу і поряд
Напишіть що в цій професії вас надихає
мотивує і цей аркуш десь на робочому
місці біля себе можете розмістити щоб
він завжди нагадував і мо вона вас до
діяльності Не забувайте рефлексувати
усвідомлюйте що є такі проблеми на які
ви не можете Вплинути і вони можуть
просто знаходитися поза зоною контролю
тому сфокусуйтеся на те що ви можете
зробити на що повпливати і так далі
батькам І далі що ми робимо включаємося
у спільноту залучаємося підтримкою колег
тому що це важливо коли ми самостійно
намагаємося переживати стрес і тривогу -
це здебільшого забирає багато часу коли
ми поділилися нам уже стає легше і
обов'язково знаходимо час для відпочинку
і що ж на таке правило визначати та
використовувати ресурси для відновлення
тобто у кожного має бути своя така
вправа техніка яку от вам стало тривожно
страшно ви за щось хвилюєтесь ви згадали
що у вас у скарбниці у вашому рюкзаку є
така вправа ви її зробили вам стало
краще легше і вирахуєтеся далі наступний
слайд і тому зараз така малесенька
техніка просто намалювати будиночок але
цей будиночок непростий Він має сенс
якщо починаючи від фундаменту
намалювали і для себе так приділіть 5
хвилин і подумайте що я хочу в собі
змінити Так зараз на вулиці війна Але
якщо ми постійно будемо говорити
обговорювати коли вона закінчиться чи
потрібно виїжджати зараз у місто
переживати за дітей Ми дуже швидко
будемо виснажуватися тому думаємо над
тим що я хочу зараз собі змінити що я
можу
[музика]
і так далі піднімаємося а вище якщо мені
стане Скажімо так не по собі цей
маленький список завжди має бути у вас
під рукою І обов'язково згадуємо тут же
про ваші корисні звички які допомагають
вам рухатися далі знову ж таки
поверх номер два чим я пишаюся в собі у
дітях у колегах не забуваємо про це і
перечитує
[музика]
у нас моя радість але воно приносить вам
радість а віконечка в цьому будиночку Це
ваші якості і які вам завжди допомагають
і на поверсі хто або що вас захищає
Тобто це певний захист який ви можете
уявно собі написати і він завжди з вами
буде сонечко то ваші мрії не забуваємо
мріяти від маленьких до Великих мрій
вони завжди будуть із вами і зліва так
це такий димохід і як і де і коли ми
можемо випустити парк не забувайте про
це не накопичуйте ми діточок вчимо
говорити про емоції випускати емоції так
само і нам потрібен час спосіб їх
випустити і також у кожного Це
індивідуально хто як зуміє навіть
порвати клаптик паперу навіть покричати
коли ніхто не чує вам також буде
допомагати тому будиночок будь ласка
забирайте у вас рюкзачок рухаємося далі
наступний слайд
визначила такі основні поняття питання
які можуть траплятися а можуть і не
траплятися що можна покласти
адміністрації батькам І фахівцям у
рюкзачок апатія Ви працюєте ви не бачите
що нічого не змінюється і нападає апатія
як же їй подолати діти згідно алгоритму
подолання апатій у вас на все має бути
план знаєте один два три але ви знаєте
що робити навіть випити філіжанку каву
це теж план дій навіть зробити якусь
рутинну роботу як ви завжди робите Але
вона у вас вже стоїть під пунктом два ви
її зробили і закреслили не забуваємо про
харчування про гігієну як би складно і
важко вам не було і обов'язково
залучайте близьких знайомих до спільної
роботи наступний слайд
знову ж таки з часом намагаюся встигнути
панічна атака також може бути або у вас
або у дитини або у ваших колег
коротенько для себе що ви можете зробити
або ж використовувати седативні дихальні
техніки якщо вони вам допомагають
Візьміть для у свій рюкзачок одну-дві
техніки які вам допомагають Якщо вам
допомагає різка зміна наприклад
положення тіла будь ласка беріть Якщо
вам допомагає використання різких
запахів Ви також можете це
використовувати словом із цього переліку
виберіть те що вам зможе допомогти і
найкраще і найлегше вам у використанні
наступне слайд
перевтома ніхто не відміняв ми працюємо
Часом буває так що нас не відпускають у
відпустку Так але ми можемо це
проконтролювати якщо ми знатимемо Що з
цим робити основним ознаками перевтоми є
відчуття знесилення неспроможність
виконувати звичайні функції Здавалося б
стає неуважними погіршення концентрації
пам'яті уваги
уповільнений процес і певні і так далі
Як ми можемо собі допомогти або ж
допомогти колегам
повноцінний сон Звісно ж по можливості
обмеження
інформаційного шуму намагайтеся
спостерігати за новинами в певний час
виділяйте на це 10-15 хвилин і достатньо
буває так щоб новини втягують нас колеги
Скажіть що у вас час для новин навіть
якщо їх розказують колеги це з 9:00 по
9:15 і так далі знову ж таки тут є
певний перелік для вашого рюкзачка
можете ознайомитися і використовувати і
не забувайте про те якщо що відбувається
з вами щось щось незрозуміле звертайтеся
за професійною допомогою зараз дуже
багато телеграм-каналів Facebook
сторінок де надається безкоштовна
психологічна підтримка далі І зараз про
рюкзачок для батьків батьки все більше
звертаються за питаннями за допомогою
Розібратися у тій чи іншій темі вони
звісно також потребують підтримки
Просвіти та моніторингу стану дітей
буває так що дитина не проявляє вдома
стрес не проявляє якісь незрозумілі
стани а приходить у садочок і їй може
педагог говорити що з дитиною щось не то
Зверніть уваги тому основні теми які
мають педагоги опрацювати це які поради
давати щоб подолання стресу у дитини
відповідно до вікових категорій тому що
в кожному віці дитина стрес Переживає
по-різному І ознаки будуть різні
наголосити на шляхи підтримки дитини в
умовах проживання достроміного досвіду
на техніки відновлення ресурсу для
батьків активності які можуть
використовувати батьки і так далі
наступний слайд
і нарешті Мені до жовтенького рюкзачка
для дитини важливим є завжди емоційний
діалог особливий вид взаємодії дорослої
людини з дитиною під час якої дитина
проявляє свої почуття переживання та
емоцій а дорослі мають відреагувати
відповідно до переживань складених
словами чи поведінкою дитини і не
забувайте про золоте правило емоційного
діалогу говорити так щоб тебе слухали і
слухати так щоб з тобою говорили і у
дітей відповідно до віку мають бути
також свої техніки зцілення ми завжди як
психологи на цьому наголошуємо що хтось
любить малювати ця дитину заспокоює
хтось любить гратися хтось у групі хтось
самостійно
викладач педагоги за цим спостерігають і
знають Хтось уже в старшій групі любить
читати і просить книжечку Можна я її
почитаю і часто спускаючись у
бомбосховище діткам які вміють читати
можна покласти книжечку розмальовку
наступний слайд і головне ми просимо
облаштувати для дитини місце спокою
часом дитина може Своєю поведінкою
показувати що вона зараз хоче побути на
самоті це те що дитині можна може бути
приємно поробити у своєму куточку там
може бути м'яка іграшка
зручне крісло або диванчик і вона може
там посидіти скільки їй і захочеться
головне щоб не пускати туди інших дітей
їх стане легше Вона виходить і туди
можуть в той куточок попроситися інші
дітки наступний слайд зараз можна
прогортати по ви можете з ними
ознайомитися це алгоритм дій при різних
стресових станах дитини тобто що ви
можете зробити Яку першу психологічну
допомогу надати дитині при тій чи іншій
ситуації і в кінці Хочу наголосити на те
що я є волонтером чудового проекту
підтримай дитину в нас є telegram-канал
де багато різно працівник вправ які
можуть використовувати батьки педагоги
вправи завдання багато рекомендацій щодо
психологічної підтримки знову ж таки на
Facebook сторінці багато ми виставляємо
інформацію в плані онлайн інтерв'ю де Ми
розказуємо куди батьки можуть звернутися
за тією чи іншою допомогою до якого до
того чи іншого фахівця логопеда
психолога реабілітолога і так далі
Сподіваюся я не дуже забрала весь час
всі до перемоги і сподіваюся що всі ми
під надійними крилами дитинства
пані Тетяна Дякую І дійсно ініціативні
практичні психологи працюють на своєму
фронті ми відчуваємо цю підтримку і
дійсно хотіли відмітити телеграм-канал
підтримає дитину і у нас на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки України
розміщені вебінари які проводили саме
наші партнери підтримай дитину і ці
вебінари були орієнтовані щодо
здійснення психологічного супроводу
дітей та педагогічних працівників захід
відбувся 3
серпня всі матеріали розміщені а також
принагідно запрошую вас долучитися до
заходу до якого буде долучити наші
колеги підтримує дитину також всі ці
лайфхаки про які щойно говорила пані
Тетяна будуть висвітлені під час
вебінару 23 серпня тому Дорогі колеги
будь ласка матеріалів дуже багато
матеріалу з доведеної ефективністю і
вони всі повинні
централізовані в закладах дошкільної
освіти Ми пишаємося українським
дошкіллям українське дошкілля найкраще і
ми єдині
Шановні колеги Сьогодні ми піднімали
дуже важливі питання впровадження в
практику роботи закладів дошкільної
освіти
освітніх напрямків саме під час
військового стану
І хочу сказати що
так як особливості роботи закладів
дошкільної освіти були сьогодні
висвітлені і за результатами нашої
локації хочу підбити і пропоную підбити
підсумки та оголосити основні меседжі
першим в яких звичайно буде берегти
життя та здоров'я всіх учасників
освітнього процесу та створювати
безпечні умови в закладах дошкільної
освіти
послідовно та систематично впроваджувати
в освітній практику дошкільної освіти
ідеї та положення стандарту дошкільної
освіти яке визначає компетентність
пріоритетним результатом дошкільної
освіти
наполегливу зберігати формат організації
життєдіяльності який відповідає дітям
дошкільного віку зі збереженням суто
дитячих видів діяльності
посилити партнерську взаємодію фахівців
закладів дошкільної освіти з батьками
вихованців поширюючи нові сучасні форми
просвітницької інформаційної
соціально-психологічної підтримки сім'ї
використовувати та активно впроваджувати
в практику роботи педагогів інноватику
закладів освіти які розміщені на сайті
Міністерства
дороги колеги Міністерство освіти і
науки України
запровадило флешмоб Повертайся до
навчання
тож закликаю всю дошкільну освіту
України приєднатися до всеукраїнського
флешмобу
повертайся до навчання адже ми прагнемо
до того щоб наші діти здобували освіту в
мирні незалежній Україні
Дякуємо вам дорогі колеги за участь у
локації дошкільна освіта під крилами
захисту бажаємо кожному з нас мирного
неба у вільні незалежній Україні та
безпечного навчального року
Дякуємо нашим захисникам збройним силам
України які боронять сьогодні нашу
державу від ворога Миру бути Слава
Україні
[музика]